[Music]
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're here for genv
episode 4 John you good genuinely Greg
Co you got a g-w graciously vivacious I
got a GW G fuel gfuel today ladies and
gentlemen sincerely one of the best
Brands we've ever worked with because I
consume their products daily so much to
the point that they send over a monthly
order to me every month but whenever I
run out I find myself running to
whatever random store might have it
available and I end up buying more
myself yes a lot of people have talked
to me about like hey Greg you look like
you've been getting a lot healthier how
do you manage that while doing all the
work that you do really a lot does come
down to this product right here I'm
giving a very sincere shout out for good
reason if you don't want to rush to a
store like myself you want to get it
delivered to you efficiently and a great
way to support the channel on top of all
that you can use our special discount
code in the description box and pin
comment to get yourself some G fuel
today it's the best I hope we can work
with them for as long as this channel
exists because I am very dependent on
them and these guys get themselves some
can shipped in them now as well we're
not even kidding cuz we come here and be
like I want a can and Greg be like well
then I'll run out of mine earlier and
he's like I bet you guys get some okay
yell at them we bring cans ourselves out
of fear yeah koi panes cans on camera
all right guys well let's get to it
before we do please go ahead and leave a
like as always full lrat and watch along
where you sync with your own copy of gen
V available for super sex rejects over
at our patreon page cover things
exclusive over there reaction Hots and
watch along is included and oh yeah
subscribe click that notification B get
notifi when our reaction for the next
episode J's up let's get to
it are we in an ear what a
POV oh oh wow we are I know the inside
of ear looks like I use an ear wax thing
maybe Sam penetrated the year canal with
the his m
oh yeah Sam skull here he's a big scary
movie fan Sam's stronger than G boy ever
was I don't know how to contain someone
like that that's painfully
obvious oh wow they don't mess up the
facility oh yeah WS no more it's a great
shot I want the whole security team on
this well half of them are dead then use
the other
half little booty no he got a good eye
no
yeah no a you left a shoe behind
evidence she'd know the students she got
got out of the hell hole it looks like a
meteor crashed here maybe Sam can jump
like ma does he landed here with Emma
and then jumped again I'd love that
guy's voice it's very peaceful maybe he
jumped like M
us we don't know who's in on it if Brink
was maybe other professors maybe Dean
shett but you guys are going to get a
green van and a talking dog and Sol
it that's right gang I told you not to
do anything stupid why don't you ever
then listen to this girl could be dead
Andre we are in over our heads just push
him to listen to you next time in over
our heads how do you guys expect to rest
to the rank of superhero get on the list
I like how they're subverting The Jock
pretty girl like they're the kindest and
like the most empathetic you look a
little bigger did you grow think I must
have swallowed something when I went
through that guy's
head brains I killed that guy he he was
a sadistic does that make you
feel any better what if he had kids wow
the first person she ever killed you
think there's a phone in here somewhere
I mean we need help oh no I I there's
only one person who can help I I I I got
to get a hold of Luke yeah about
that your brother died what are you
talking about nothing could kill Luke
he's he's he's he's too strong wrong
only Luke can kill Luke himself wait no
sorry
yes good thing you're tiny right now
supero superhero
Landing I'm here Sam you leave too I
won't don't get near him you will
he'll flick you
away everybody always leaves me promise
I'm with you I wonder how they filmed
this with them because it really feels
like they're two actors in the same room
scattered Clues and hidden corners of
Darkness oh oh no fought plus I'm Tech
Knight and I won't stop searching hey
did you hear that TCH Knight oh
truth he's like a billionaire Iron Man
Batman inspiration first appearance but
good oh definitely you can test the most
moral great Bruce Wayne standing but
tragedy has rocked this institution to
its core the rising star who took life
but why did the Golden Boy Who had
everything this whole case is a rabbit
hole into the unknown and I won't stop
plunging its
depths he does a lot of Robin boning
that's a lot of
sorry K guys car plunging its depths I
mean what come on let's go again let's
reset I like him already it's an honor
to have such an esteemed alumnus back
with us
you hate that I'm here I make
you nervous seems like you want to make
her nervous was it iron cast who himself
the morning after you interrogated him
strange how many of your subjects and
stand up dead or beaten into
Comas I myself have nothing to hide are
you sure about that small beat of sweat
on your
brow detective adrenaline seeping from
your pores and you're ovulating by the
way o she's adductive what has Ashley
told you did she tell me that Golden Boy
killed Brink in a misguided attempt to
rescue his brother from the woods so you
know exactly
why it's our job to make sure no no one
else knows and how do you intend to do
that well the usual misdirection
opusc find a py and destroy their life
pick a card any card I'm going to Johnny
dab someone so hard they're going to
want to crawl into a hole and die
nice just stay away from the top five
ouch Jesu christe there's always more
where they came from you'll manage those
giant de channels are going to have
plenty of content oh yeah a lot of
people buying new houses now I'm I'm
going to need access to campus
surveillance a full list of golden boys
classmates girlfriends a couple of
reflectors from the film department yes
Roy forgot our bounces got to get that
soft light boy quality life for Tech
Knight I hope he brought his Ward I like
his szy charm but he didn't just Batman
disappear on her he got cuz he's Bruce
Wayne right now kind of that's fair I
like the Sherlock choice of the zoom
inss too you look high but me no not at
all
sorry what are you on and I'm sorry I
should have listened I don't know where
Emma is and I don't know what to do that
might also be a tiny bit
nice you guys are way too comfortable
with each other he just died and my dad
knows about the woods what they're doing
and he told me to drop it maybe he
trying to protect you well yeah protect
and cover up this whole time he was
mixed up in all this he's not the man
that I thought he was you don't know if
he's mixed up in it or if he just knows
about it yeah what do he tell you
sheth's lover was a handsome arrogant
venture capitalist and now staying on
the floor of his Chef's Kitchen was his
demise crushed under all 700 lb of his
girlfriend Jesus smothering the drag
Forest ruus right I heard you're a
psychic yeah think jamanji baseball
backa so you're looking for your
roommate but she's not the only girl
you're looking for sister I don't have
any money there are other ways you can
thank me yes let's do this extortion hey
come on I'm with you is that his
quote I can see your friend is is she
okay she looks rough come
closer I need a stronger connection come
a little closer than you see how does
her connection make it strong sketchy
guy
this dude's like an Aryan Ramy
mik open the godamn swear to
God whoa what is happening off I'm busy
oh
no what the it's not what it looks like
whoa on
Earth that's a spicy meat
ball
what what did she blood B the thingy I
think she did nice
work come on where the blood was
flowing
jeez wow oh I'm so disoriented right
that was so much that was
random you're really going to throw it
all away I'm not throwing it all away
I'm not but Emma's my friend what
happened to you don't owe anyone
anything and to leave you the alone
maybe I was wrong maybe you're an idiot
you idiot you're full of she
can't help you you know I'm right you're
just scared I hope these two hook up
Tech night is on campus if he finds out
what you're doing you're lucky you end
up in prison he people up since when do
you care about anyone not named Jordan
cared about Luke how do you guys move on
past what just happened so fast know
what's going on you guys are just like
it's just another day exploded his okay
we're back because I distracted him tag
team
explosion essay must be a big just thing
that happens constantly in this world
with pow it is in the comic and I
imagine in college but combination's a
lot five four
three why did he do it Andre I don't
know I think it's obvious he couldn't
hack it hack it you're stronger than all
of us well that must have been hard for
you knowing that You' never beat him oh
it's fine oh interesting if he wasn't at
this school you would have been number
one maybe I don't know prank would have
made sure of it ouch oh man you are a
provocator have you always been angry at
Golden Boy no I loved him you gave your
whole life to him who's going to break
how did you not know he was this
Disturbed wish I had known it kills me
that I missed it take that glove off I
take your hand
off what did he say to you just before
he died daddy loved
me tell the LIE how long have you been
eating golden boys girlfriends whoa who
whoa who who
man the number one spot he found out
about you and Kate cracked no no that
didn't happen until so it did happen no
you get treated like a god here what
kind of hero chicken to do anything
heroic oh damn are we going to have like
actual Heroes out of our soups it's up
to the Next Generation
man we'll find it in the
edit I also love that his power of
deduction is like that specific it's a
good Batman joke it's like superp power
but he's a human it's embarrassing you
know I'm not the best judge for what's
humiliating I used to put stuff up my
butt for money I'm
kidding yeah no it wasn't for
money after what you did for me I would
eat your puke I take it back you are
sick I know multiple Mental
Hospitals a so well cast what if under
my shirt it was all nipple like your
nipple so big it band your whole torso
no like a triple nipple except it's a
Quin quadruple nipple what if I just had
like 50 nipples under my shirt I can
live with
that do you let's see things I worry
about
please stop
[Music]
no shut
up I do worry about his sanity your
roommate's Emma she's the one who gets
small why have you seen her recently
stays the night at this guy Austin's
place every night what's this
about I'm just checking she's okay she
missed a few classes it's scary to lie
when there's a lie detector on campus we
are fortunate to have a guest lecturer
who revolutionized the field in
superhero crime fighting so
sweet Tech
Knight on camera to walk back today we
will focus on interrogation techniques
that I
developed what is it with the the the
Rings I will need a
volunteer choose the one who's not
raising their hand this is going to go
poorly for anyone yep one of the five
Marie Maro the guardian of gulan walk me
through that day I've told this story a
lot but not the whole story
Jordan why were you going to see Brink I
wanted to discuss my class
schedule damn it can you control the
blood flow in your oh and your ocular
yeah is that nerve not dilate was it to
talk about his distaste for
you
Bullseye heart rate just elevated wow
you can really teach this to other
people can't you people with this
detective
skill he was going to expel you wasn't
he no were you in on it with Luke no I
didn't do anything now or then then now
both is it I couldn't stop Luke uhoh I
went to Brinks because he kicked me out
I saw Luke and iing ran the only reason
I'm still alive is because Jordan Lee
held him off long enough for me to get
away wow is this all going to be on VA
plug
on camera right now does Jordan's
ranking go up Jordan's the hero not me
and that's how you break a witness
folks but only you can pull that off
yeah it's literally a
power so you know you're going to want
to zoom in hyperfocus on their arteries
smell their adrenaline their
pupil no one will believe Marie Maro is
responsible for Golden Boy demise I
can't pin this on any of these kids pity
for your show you should interrogate her
which is why I'm going to pin it on you
I shouldn't go after the top five they
could be real earners ohug you have no
evidence I've done anything wrong what
about Sam escaping from the woods hell
yeah yeah I saw it on your face when I
first brought up his name wait till vaud
finds out I'd say taking the fall for
Golden Boy is getting off easy does she
have a secret superpower if she's the
dean I have to imagine she would so in
the comics he's like super horny and
there's some stuff with Robin I don't
remember the like the amount of Bruce
Wayne I'm really curious how they land
that oh he crazy crazy please no can't
run forever you know a little bit like
black noir going to find you and hurt
you again Jason Ritter Jason
Ritter Jason Ritter
oh it'll be all your fault you couldn't
protect her no won let them there's only
one way to make sure AVU Fe this is
great you know who hurt you he hurts
everyone in the woods a Dr cardosa ding
ding ding somehow it's creepier as a
puppet well it's playing on the
childhood innocence here just just just
shut up television Jason
R Dr cardosa haven't you been listening
he's dangerous and I have to stop him no
no more talking some great editing here
he hurt me and he won't leave me Al
alone okay Sam I don't know what's wrong
what can I do how can I help you keep
just stop just stop please stop
stop oh no man oh
dude my God no he's hulking
away oh didn't repair the crotch don't
need
to
[Music]
I'm crushing your
head oh oh public don't know what I do
without you oh it's nothing in that case
you're welcome for nothing this is not
good to do in public guys no he he just
died I didn't ask you to do that yeah
you did specifically several times
actually but I didn't want you to bury
yourself in the process you keep doing
the dumb thing
[Music]
my angle is that sometimes people don't
have an angle sometimes they're just
actual human beings what what's the
everyone's got a motive I was just
talking okay you're the only one
who actually Golden Boy yeah but I'm so
scared you guys should comfort each
other Craig has goals I have motives yes
yes oh oh you don't need to change which
one either
or knew it called
it I'm sorry that's not what you meant
yo you pull them in no pull them
in come out yeah come
out good for Jordan good for
her it's interesting for this guy hey we
we just need you on set for the kissing
scene can you just click back in thanks
my hook H up radar is so strong dude
oh a lot is
happening true that sister she's still
bloody sorry Sam's going after Dr cusa
we have to stop him who Luke's brother
it's actually kind of hot no who car do
he used to work with Brink I know where
he lives oh know where he lives did
you recently visit the brain tumor
Center at John's Hopkins you have a
small tumor in your brain will
eventually be fatal but I imagine you
already know that i'
Hazard compilation of your greatest
hits is's he doing stuff with this stuff
he is do
stuff full shaped
stuff
yes Corey your 18 to 49 demo will fare
when we broadcast you despoiling every
single hole you come
across what you you
want there's nothing to find at God you
or with me nothing to tell V and no
reason to stay long as you're off campus
by end of day this video stays off
Instagram hell yeah she's like the
meline still well it's easier to proe
the dark hole of
conspiracy my man dark hole fortunately
gulan University remains as resilient as
[Laughter]
ever with this case behind me I move on
to the next mystery to seek out the
whole
truth oh my god
dude oh man uh give me a few minutes
alone please how what did you the tree
is right here it's a compulsion it's a
compulsion oh you know Batman may not do
certain things to Catwoman but this
Batman does plenty I noticed when he
said the 20 years since he's been at
class that program that there was a
sense of existentialism and his delivery
and then now finding about the tumor
makes a lot more
sense s look at me look at me murder him
Sam you're not real you're
all puppets I don't want to oh man this
jarring editing
yeah oh God go go go go Sam Sam I'm here
look at
me oh
wow damn oh we're
X-Men sham Sam you don't want to do this
you don't want to do this Sam
Sam you said I was your hero okay let me
help you again no they're not this is
problem hey guys some sensitivity some
sensitivity dude
dude
[Music]
ow O
no can she get bigger oh my God giant
woman is she got a giant
[Music]
woman oh man keep now you're fighting
the brother
[Music]
whoa she H we love Luke when we found
out he was trying to rescue you we tried
to
help damn
giant girl let me go that's
disturbing wherever we go we promise
we're in this together Sam we're going
to make this right I
promise
we'll oh
no what the hell is going on
whoa
what God no my dude
no no with it on yeah accessories
[Music]
tools of course gotta leave us with a
little Moment of
Zen
what uh what happened did they pull in
the psychic guy to
to like neutralize the situation bring
them all and I don't know what just
happened how we went to the bed yeah
from the it's exactly like the cut with
the psychic guy so I wonder if either
somebody else has his similar power or
if they brought him in as their
neutralizer or
something I'm
confused this this is this interesting
episode I was like is there something
wrong with the footage I was like did
the internet cut out like it felt like a
disassoc what just
happened I'm still confused narratively
I cannot explain that Derek Wilson I
hope he's related to the other Wilson
because he's incredible what just
happened how were they in bed how did
they get what how did they leave the
house they were X-Men
yeah um all right I guess let's try to
take in what just
happened yeah I need to I'm immediately
like Message Board reading in my head
like what is it
I rarely want to read what people are
thinking but I'm like what just happened
that was intentional right you must well
there was the music cut and everything
yeah yeah no it's because that threw in
his little Montage too is implying that
it's like a a jump cut of like you know
sexy time but like what narratively I
don't understand yeah I don't I don't
get it they just needed some way to end
the episode and then next time they'll
cut back to midf fight then show us the
chronology of how they all got back yeah
like there must be a reason cuz she was
like mids sentence which like we know
how the sentence ended so they cut it
off at a place that we'd understand what
was going to happen next but then the
jump cut and then the further jump cut
implies there has to be something to
like narratively explain like is there a
psychic like you said is there like
maybe that's the dean's P what's
happening but why would the
psychic do specifically
that like when the time Omission was
explained through strong pheromones with
her getting like assaulted and then you
know explosion unless of course it might
have been a memory wipe situation could
be you know where like they actually
retriev Sam and then they wipe the
memories of them yeah it could be and so
they were playing it like okay from the
moment because what what happened is
that Jordan and Marie were about to hook
up and then cricet came in and oh and
now they've got cricket and yeah like
they took cricket and Sam yeah or or
like so it's like okay let's just wipe
the memory and then just put them in bed
together so that way that's when they
that's so clever if that's if that's
what happened I'm just making it guess
it's an interesting thing to have that
twice in an episode because once it was
pheromones now it's like a mind wipe but
they did talk about mind wiping people
in the episode first two oh yeah they
they WIP they mind wiped about Sam prior
and yeah so maybe it was like the Jordan
moment was about to they were about to
get after it and then they just wiped
back to them finishing yeah yeah in the
Doctor's house too yeah maybe they had
some kind of woods related you know like
alarm or something he can sound that'll
get people in there and then yeah maybe
they can just wipe the memories Place
everybody back and then clean up this
mess and that was pretty public like the
doctor was alive he would have called
somebody yeah yeah and it's like you
know the mess of them breaking in is
like yeah that puts their like careers
and and and their you know schooling at
risk but at the same time you know I
feel like it also stands to it stands a
threat to revealing the woods and what's
really going on down there so maybe they
did just like clean this up and then
yeah probably take Sam and cricket and
imprison them and all the jaring editing
for his Insanity was like that
translates into like you know us being
disoriented which they use well for the
edit but now us being disoriented got to
be purposeful yeah yeah maybe the
psychic thing was a mislead maybe it
could be to make you think it might have
been that like the like the jump cut
earlier was disorienting so this or
maybe they mind WIP via psychic maybe
they use psychic to mind wipe oh yeah
maybe he's how they do
it I thought it was I thought it was
really odd placement it didn't feel like
an intentional jump cut well I think I'm
saying like the use of the psychic in
this episode I thought was just odd in
total like okay I understand her talking
to the psychic to but it did seem like a
forced DSX Machina like we need this
thing yeah like and for another you know
gross out bit um that that the boys
Universe does and and then they they're
kind of imp passive reaction to I'm like
I still feel like they would be very uh
disturbed by what just happened at least
Marie even though I know they seem some
horrible but that is a very
disturbing you know sexually graphic
violent thing to suddenly witness and go
through and to uh also um do to someone
even though it is uh protecting yourself
essentially uh it's so I'm like okay
this whole thing just kind of feels it
felt like off to me I'm like all right I
get gross out gag humor in the boys but
this whole thing feels like just odd uh
instead of fitting um but maybe that was
placed to establish the psychic side of
it and then they use a PSY and I hope so
yeah yeah because there's a time because
there is a a gap there for Marie when
she is on the bench to now she's in
because it almost plays like a vision
when you first are there then it's not
actually a vision it's a thing that's
really happening yeah time removal it's
like the initial jar of that moment does
work I think in editing where it's like
oh we were just on the bench and now
we're here what's going on but yeah it's
the H it's the handling of the gag that
feels a bit strange and it feels like
one of those bits of like yeah it's well
within this universe for this guy to be
a complete creep but at the same time we
got to get like a weird gor gag we
haven't had a weird gor gag in a while
and a gross sex one it's been 40 minutes
since a day we got to bring in a we got
to do one somewhere you know and then
let's get back to the plot you know yeah
yeah um overall this episode felt the
most uh disorganized obviously besides
those two cuts but if that was the
purpose I would really like it like in
the greater scheme of the Season like if
it was
intentionally disorganized and messy
because all the tech Knight stuff was
also very efficient and lean like they
did really good editing around like you
know intermixing like his lore and
backstory and like Tech knight uh you
know has that same fetish uh SL disorder
in the comic and I I missed his name
dropped so like I I missed the initial
joke but once I realized who he was like
that was really played well so it's not
like the episode was messy but I think
enough was messy I'm hoping it was
conscious well the episode's perspective
is that of like paranoia what is real
what isn't real the entire time you know
from Sam's perspective of constantly
questioning what is reality the way they
play with the psychic of what is real
what isn't real even with tech Knight of
trying to uncover the truth of behind
everyone's deception and lies and lesser
even Aaron discovering like you know how
deep this goes
them trying to unravel that mystery and
then all them being disoriented by Tech
Knight being able to rip things apart
like even the interrogation is its own
way like truths being revealed like
disorienting yeah
yeah strange very strange episode yeah
no it was Str is it is very strange and
I guess like watching however episode
five plays out would be a little bit
more telling of how this one um
ultimately factors into the bigger
equation of things it's funny that the
first three were we were saying like
week one two and three could have been
separate but this episode form like the
next one like yeah this feels the least
like its own you could watch each of the
they're all part of an ongoing story but
each of them feels well-rounded in
isolation up to this point and this one
certainly feels like okay this is like
you know another interstitial chapter on
the way to the next part of the plot uh
it it has that feeling of like yeah we
learned some stuff you know we we rubbed
up against a new potential villain and
the most like progress we made was at
least getting Sam out and and and that
situation but we don't really even know
how that ends up right now it seems like
he's most likely back in you know the
the woods so I feel like in a way it is
one of those more like let's explore
some Stakes let's explore some
uncomfortable situations for the
characters but it doesn't feel as much
like we're moving things along as in in
a way that it it felt like it was going
to I don't know like when they all have
that showdown at the end I was like oh
damn we're already getting to something
like this you know we're already kind of
and I'm sure there will be a reward to
the you know rug pool at the very end
but as it stands just right now like
yeah it it does kind of I don't know
what to call it because it's not filler
you know because it's still doing things
for the characters and it's still
expounding on things but it doesn't feel
as substantial as just like oh yeah you
know like I could have like we've said
of the past three episodes I could have
taken one of these and just chewed on it
all week you know I think it's good
though for the internet culture to have
something like this though because now
every instead of having the first three
at once everybody talked about it a
little bit and now everyone that jumped
on the first three episodes this is the
first time they've been like well I have
to wait a week and everyone is going to
be saying like did yours break too like
I feel like Twitter is gonna be like
really alive waiting for a week for this
this might build an audience this might
grow it because it's everyone now
waiting going like what the hell yeah
sure that's a good that's a good time to
break it up is like have your three that
feel like you've got some closure wait
have one that's insanely disorienting
grow your audience even more because
everybody's discourse
yeah well I think there I I just think
there are some beats though because a
lot about it that I loved I mean I love
Tech Knight's portrayal I I think like
um like a Bruce Wayne who's like out in
public and showing he's got powers
instead of like uh dual identity and it
except his like hidden identities that
he he's like a
pervert Psychopathic per he's like he's
more of like if Bruce Wayne was American
Psycho yeah and I really like that
portrayal and I think the actor did a
fantastic job of of like with his on
camera presence and his public charm
really does shine but it meshes well
with when the camera's not rolling as
well I think he was excellent and and um
I I liked uh the the action moments were
cool I really like I can't remember her
freaking name which one Cricket yeah
Emma Emma Emma yeah I really like Emma
here and um even the reveal of her power
which it seemed like a lot of people
weren't aware that she could actually do
herself uh was really was really cool
like the exact opposite
effect you know consume now great on TV
and biging she's my favorite character
for sure I think she's great I think
she's amazing and I I love her chemistry
as well with
Sam and there's some just little beats
like I said I don't want to harp too
much on that one beat with the psychic
that I thought was really odd but I I
did think it was odd though that not
much of a even though my radar was like
yeah they're going to hook up when it
came I thought it was a little odd um
other than like I thought we were still
building sexual tension with them like
it'd be the next time like that would be
like someone would come in the room
they'd stop then next yeah I didn't
think it would be like oh it's happening
now and and and then the also the
Revelation that she she did
unveil not not just to Tech Knight but
to a bunch of people in the room yeah
and with CER present at least but the
cameras aren't live right they're it is
a recording so yeah I imagine it's just
be in the room but people people in the
room yeah those people in the room you
think that would be more the next day at
school she's like number Revelation
Stakes at hand here and ammo for fellow
students to use against her climb R yeah
yeah so I thought there would be a
little bit more and maybe there will be
it just kind of felt a little
inconsequential and only only to the
drama between Jordan and Marie which
just led to them hooking up
seems like a real positive that she told
everyone that she doesn't have powers
yeah so uh yeah that that moment still
played a little strange to me as well uh
but because it's like episode four out
out of what eight eight that I'm I'm
sort of just waiting to see how it
factors in versus versus judging you
know what the overall narrative is with
it but right now yeah there's just a
couple of things I played a little bit
whereas like the other ones I didn't
really have much of a critical criticism
towards we here I'm like kind of a
little little suspicious of how some
things are going to play out and if
they're actually good or effective but
still overall I really enjoyed my time
here um yeah sometimes I do and I I kind
of feel this way with the boys too
sometimes I I feel like you guys
probably eat up some of the more like
gross out gags more than I do for me
sometimes I'm
like I don't know I'm like it's kind of
amusing but the times it does feel like
they're they're they're just doing it to
do it I mean it ratings yeah no that's
how I felt about this one here like I I
I'm not you know bring me a a macro
eggplant Emoji you know like I'm not
necessarily like coming to the show for
that stuff that's not necessarily my my
flavor like that I seek out I can enjoy
that but here yeah no like that gag
while you know wild and shocking you
know didn't really add much to the even
the holes joke thing was kind of like
all right well I that's so the comic was
very much of the time of how much can we
push a boundary and I I think I
explained this episode one but this was
when everyone was doing commentary on
stuff so this became a commentary on the
commentary almost like once scary movie
had done seven scary movies there was
things making fun of scary movie I feel
like the boys was the thing that was
like okay we've got the authority we've
got the Supreme uh Squad I forget the
last but we've got all these
commentaries on team books and the boys
was like we want to look at the overall
comic industry and Perry
but we're going to instead of pushing
the violence or the political commentary
we're going to push the gross out
because 2006 was like the age of gross
out sexualization stuff so I feel like
the show uh the boys was able to saiz
that politically and to change
everything to being like a commentary on
our pop culture system whereas this show
is more of a commentary on College and
like growing up but it does tie more
into sexualization more directly so
they're able to do a lot more of the
comic stuff which is then in turn
hypersexualizing gross out stuff so
honestly this feels more directly akin
to the boys comic than the boys does but
it also seems like an opportunity for
some of the sensibilities a very 06 time
to be like what if dick jokes every
episode like it seems very much that so
it does feel more like the the comic but
the comic feels very of a time so I
don't know how much this translates but
I think it's also great for the ratings
for Amazon to have a dick joking episode
like everyone's going to be talking
about exploding
sure like it's just it works narratively
for the sales with which is Amazon
ironically the vot parallel here yeah
yeah vot plus is selling
D I mean the the whole thing is a bit
more of like a character Trope or
character beat for him so like yeah I
don't know like th those things are all
they work on me but I wouldn't say
they're like a draw for the holes thing
worked for me better than the exploding
D they make me squirm and laugh but yeah
the whole thing is direct like there I
remember a double page spread in the
comic of like it lands the the final bit
is him uh going at Robin and I was like
like it was very very a lot in the comic
book and this was like I was really
worried for some poor Ward oh yeah but
that'd be a great Joseph Gordon Le
came fair enough oh to live on that
timeline fair enough Donal whoever oh
like any Robin like stand in like it' be
funny if it was the more obscure uh I
mean generally I like the just to
clarify generally I like the the
vulgarity yeah generally I really enjoy
it um but but it works times where I
feel like it's a little forced it works
best when it's narratively serving
whereas this felt like they were like
it's been a little bit yeah yeah when
you believe it's a part of this world
that you happen to be passing through
not yeah like we need to drop one of
these in here cuz that's what we do yeah
I I would say of the episodes this was
my least favorite but it's in part
because of all the things we just
mentioned but also I do feel like it is
suffering from it needs to be talked
about before the next episode this one's
the only one that feels kind of
incomplete sure yeah but maybe that's
the point I think it is it's the start
of act to yeah and it's like it's it's
it's a show not a movie in a way I feel
like if you're shifting away from okay
we just dropped three now we got to drop
one I think maybe there's a strategy in
dropping one that feels like this may
improve with f the upcoming episodes or
something like the context of this might
solidify itself and calcify when we get
to the rest of what's happening I think
we'll get the rest of the puzzle next
episode I I think I think they should
have made it it would have served to
help make it clear
what what happened in that cut it like
is it a memory are they do they not
remember what happened did they just go
back and hook up guess I guess I would
have ended it there instead of tagging
it with tech Knight because then I think
the mystery lingers a little bit because
let's say it is memory wipe and they
don't remember then it then then it's
like o what like how'd that happen you
and I would have been more jarring to
have them in bed together then credits
than the joke yeah mid credits the yeah
the joke yeah I would throw the tech KN
at the post credit like I'd throw that
at the end and then you've got that like
what's happening and it feels more
resolved than a montage yeah yeah
totally yeah it was a little weird cuz
it's like a double button yeah it's like
why are we doing two bits and also why
is there a songs these things don't
connect yeah totally no it's the most
sort of uh it's the least refined
episode it's it's like it's one of those
things where it's like all the things
I've Loved about the show so far are in
here and like there's lots of good work
in here but yeah it's just like the
proportions don't feel as sad satisfying
as everything up till now but not in a
way that makes me go oh no the show's
dropping off or or you know well because
we had some uh worries and criticisms
that means we hated it we hated it let
the record show come and we always hate
everything too unless we love every and
and and all we're doing really though is
we're just taking some other discourse
we heard on the internet and just
regurgitate here we don't know how to
form an opinion we have none of our
opinions what are we shows of this week
what be like in the last six days
because that's what we actually like
what audience are we Playa to get views
let's oh boy comment below and let us
know what we think please that's what
it's for and let us know what to think
next week so we can prepare like
subscribe and let us know how we
[Music]
feel